in this video we'll talk about shigella
this is a high yield video for USMLE
step one stay tuned till the end
shigella is the causative bacteria for
shigellosis which is a bacterial
dysentery and this affects the young
children most
is the causative organism for the
pandemic of shika dysentery
and in past
it has happened in Japan southeast Asia
America and Africa so it was pretty
common in 1990s and early 90s
in this video we'll talk about the
microbiology pathology
identification of shigella and
ultimately the treatment of shigellosis
so shigella is a grum negative Rod
shaped bacteria which is clearly visible
under a microscopic staining
it's non-motile non-spore forming and
belongs to the family of enterobacteria
C do you remember salmonella they are
kind of like close cousin of shigella
and there are mainly four species of
shigella which are underlying these
disease these are shigela dysentery
flexnery voidy and Sony it's important
to note that most strains do not produce
gas in mixed acid fermentation of
glucose test
let's talk about the transmission of
sigela shigella is transmitted through
contaminated food or water
so the fecal oral root of transmission
is pretty common for shigella
apart from these roots of transmission
it can be TR it can be transmitted via
unpasteurized milk raw meat which is not
properly washed or contact with poultry
animals which are infected with this
bacteria
when it comes to pathogenesis shigella
actually affect the large intestine the
most and it leads to inflammation and
damage of the cells of the large
intestine
it also produce a exotoxin known as
Shiga toxin that can create the
situation more complicated and it is the
it is responsible for more severe
infection
initially the shigella gets endocytosed
by the
large intestine cells the epithelial
cells of the mucous mucous layer then
shigala can escape from the macrophages
because it grows intercellularly
and eventually
what happens is shigella can invade the
nearby cell
and in this process shigala can
literally destroy the cells of the mucus
this leads to severe cramp
and abdominal pain
as well as it leads to bloody diarrhea
that means blood in the stool which are
pretty characteristic of shigellosis
now let's talk about the identification
of shigella in lab from a stool test
during the acute phase of the illness
one can detect shigela with the help of
Hector nagar or with the help of
salmonella agar because in salmonella
agar salmonella and shigella all enteric
pathogens would be isolated via
different characteristics
let's talk about the treatment the
vaccine of shigella is in progress but
right now it's basically a bacterial
disease which can be treated with
antibiotics ciprofloxacin and
azithromycin are the antibiotic of
choice other than that replenishing the
body fluid is absolutely necessary in
case of severe dehydration
hospitalization and IV fluid injection
might be necessary so I hope this video
was useful if you like this video give
it a quick thumbs up don't forget to
like share and subscribe you can get
more notes and flash cards in our
Facebook page links are provided in the
description you can support our Channel
using super thanks you can pay via paytm
PayPal or UPI see you in next video